now to Our Guest today Andy he's a
professor both at the GSB and in
political science
and um yeah he's been
a co-director of of seeper and uh wait
uh the center for polarization research
yeah polarization lab and also he'll be
teaching a course next quarter on uh
well Dallas but like blockchain
governments more more generally which
will be cross-listed across a whole
bunch of different schools for for
probably the first time ever so
um yeah he'll be he'll be telling you a
little bit more about that as well and
you can see it's his website but yeah
um I'll let you take it away great thank
you uh yeah just to briefly before I get
into my material we are teaching a new
class on blockchain governance uh mostly
about Dows how they work
um practical questions about Dao's view
from social science A View From law as
well as how to actually build them and
so this will be co-taught between me
coming from the business school which is
why it's a GSB listed class Dan Bonnet
in the Cs department and Jeff stranad in
the law school so it'll be a pretty cool
exciting kind of like cross Stamford
um class about blockchain governance and
I I hope uh people will take it and yeah
don't hesitate to email me if you have
any questions about it it's supposed to
be open everyone no prereqs should be
super fun uh cool okay I'm gonna dive in
uh please interrupt me at any time if
anything's not clear or if you just have
questions I purposefully made the number
of slides pretty small I'm usually a
pretty succinct person I'm relatively
confident I'll get through everything so
please don't hesitate to interrupt at
any time and I gather there's a mic you
can use if you want to be on the video
cool okay uh just to get disclosures out
of the way I get Consulting income from
a 16z crypto and meta which is relevant
for some of what I'm going to talk about
uh and what I want to talk about today
is governance so my background as we
just said is from political science I've
historically mostly studied how you
design
constitutions systems of government for
the real world but over the last five
years I've spent more and more of my
time in the digital world trying to
understand how we could write
constitutions or Design Systems of
governance for different kinds of online
communities or platforms and so when I
say governance what I mean is the system
system that determines who has the power
to make decisions and the process by
which they make those decisions it's
really Central to a lot of human society
to decide how you're going to do those
things and it affects kind of everything
and the point I want to make just to
motivate everything I'm going to talk
about today is that web 3 or crypto a
lot of the motivation essentially all of
the motivation has something to do with
governance right if you look at what
people say about web3 and blockchain the
whole point is it's supposed to be the
system for making strong commitments
this idea like as Tim ruffgarden puts it
right a computer in the sky that no one
owns and you can use that computer to
make commitments to one another you can
create property rights strong
enforceable contracts and so forth and
the whole justification for why we're
interested in that has something to do
with this idea of Distributing out power
or decentralizing power whatever you
want to call it and so it really is
about governance and if we can get
governance to work well then I think
there's a huge amount of Promise in this
whole space but of course what we've
seen today is that getting governance to
work well is actually super super hard
and we all know that from our own
experience in the real world it's very
hard to point to anywhere in the real
world where you're like yeah super easy
to solve that Collective Choice problem
right some societies some cities some
countries some clubs seem to be better
at it than others but it's super super
hard everywhere and so it shouldn't be
that surprising that we're still in the
early stages of figuring this out for
web 3-2 and so that's kind of what I
want to talk about today is what we've
seen so far in terms of governance in
web 3 what some of the key problems are
some examples of how different projects
are dealing with this and so forth and
I'm going to be drawing largely here
I'll say from my experience of working
with a bunch of different Dow projects
trying to understand their governance
problems
and trying to draw analogies from what
I've seen in the physical world to
design new ways of of doing governance
for web 3. okay so let me just on that
point
just tell you very quickly something I'm
sure you probably all already have a
sense of which is that what's going on
in in crypto and on the internet more
generally is a very interesting and a
logical extension of what's come before
so sometimes you'll see rhetoric about
how this is all super new and different
and in some ways of course it is but
it's also worth reflecting on and
thinking about the fact that we can
probably learn a lot from what's
happened before because a lot of the
same challenges and problems have come
up so let me give you 30 seconds of
background on corporate governance and
30 seconds of backgrounds on on
Democracy there's a lot of other people
on campus you could you could go very
deep on these topics with corporate
governance okay we start out maybe 600
700 years ago people want to invest in
projects they want to launch a ship to
go somewhere or something and maybe find
something worth money okay at first
maybe you're one investor you fund the
whole thing yourself you pay attention
to it it goes well whatever then over
time you're like maybe I should invest
in a bunch of these and then a bunch of
other people I like like I should also
invest in these now suddenly you each
have a portfolio of these Investments
and you can't spend all your time
monitoring it right you're invested in a
bunch of things so are a lot of other
people you start to think I'm too busy
and also I'm just one of a hundred
people who invested in this thing why
should I pay any attention to it and
things start to go wrong people's money
gets stolen might sound familiar some
things we've heard about here recently
uh so what do you do well we invent this
whole apparatus to monitor the
Investments and to try to make them go
well and to prevent theft and to prevent
other kinds of mistakes and what does
that structure look like well we have
shareholders that vote on things but we
don't expect shareholders to vote on
everything because it's too hard to ask
them to vote on everything they don't
show up to do it they don't know what
they need to know to do it and they're
just one of hundreds or thousands of
shareholders so why should they learn so
what do we do instead we have a board we
have a board of a small number of people
who are paid
to monitor on our behalf to be our
agents monitoring this Corporation
that's the core insight to some extent
of corporate governance there's a lot of
other things too but that's like a
really key part of it the idea that we
elect a board that represents us as
shareholders to monitor the investment
that's exactly what we see to some
extent going on in Dallas today right we
have this sort of like the exact same
idea that when there were just a couple
of us we could kind of vote on
everything and then Dow started to get
bigger and more people entered them and
it started to become impractical really
really quickly and we started to see a
lot of things go wrong
and now one of the things you'll see a
lot in the Dow space right is people
saying maybe there should be a council
that's or maybe there should be a group
of delegates that oversee these things
for us on a regular basis and maybe we
should pay them and so I just want to
point out there's a lot of parallels
here to corporate governance obviously
there's also a lot of parallels to
democracy the exact same kind of thing
happened in democracy
when it's 10 or 15 people in a
settlement together you can kind of talk
everything out and just figure it out
and then as it starts to scale it gets
harder to do that and you might have a
similar calculus to what I described
with corporate governance why should I
pay attention to everything I have other
stuff I have to do and there's 500
people here can't some of them do it I'm
not going to weigh in it wouldn't matter
if I did anyways I'm not I'm just one
person right and so democracy goes
through the exact same type of evolution
prior to corporate governance and they
come up with very a similar set of
solutions and this is where corporate
governance got a lot of their ideas from
right we started electing
representatives whose full-time job it
was to monitor the goings-on of the
government on our behalf and to steer it
in directions we want it to go in
obviously it doesn't work smoothly all
the time maybe an understatement but
it's a lot better than the alternative
which is so-called direct democracy
which you won't see any society on Earth
use for any sustainable amount of time
because it simply doesn't work and
that's what Dows are figuring out right
now they've already pretty much figured
it out right it just doesn't work so
what can you do instead that's what I
want to talk about today is like what
are Dows doing how does it borrow from
these histories but how is it new and
different and I just want to say as a
political scientist it's a crazy
exciting time because if there really
should be something new here the
technology really is different so we're
not going to completely reinvent the
wheel there's a lot we can borrow but
there are new things here that are
different right we can vote in different
ways we can assign out power in
different ways we can meet on different
frequencies we can make different types
of decisions thanks to technology so
that's what I'm going to talk about
today
the way I want to structure this talk is
kind of along the lines of the meetings
that I have with projects so that if you
know if you're thinking of starting a
project you're thinking of working with
a project hopefully like this will be
right on point for the kinds of things
you should be thinking about and I kind
of want to organize that whole thing
around one question which is when you
let's say want to build a dow
what do you want governance to do for
you and the reason I want to frame it
this way is sometimes we have this
tendency in life it's just natural in a
lot of domains
um to start with the tool and then
decide what it's for and this definitely
happens sometimes in web3 sure we've all
experienced this at some point right and
so someone might just say I need to have
governance I don't know why but it's
like a cool thing in web 3 and so I need
it and obviously that is not the way to
figure out exactly how to design
something for success and so what you
really want to do is start with what is
the goal you're trying to solve because
depending on that goal you might
actually arrive at different structures
right and so that's why it's not always
useful sometimes you'll see blog posts
or you know Tweets in the space that are
kind of like this is the way governance
should work it should be all token
voting it should be no token voting
those both could be right answers for
different use cases and so you have to
start with the motivation what are you
trying to accomplish with your
governance structure
there's surely a lot of potential
answers to that and I don't want to
pretend to have all of them or even most
of them so I'm just going to hit on
three possible justifications for Dow
governance that I have seen come up and
that I think also make sense but this is
not meant to be an exhaustive list but
those three things that I'm going to go
through in some detail are you might
want to set up decentralized governance
so that your protocol is censorship
resistant so that there's no single
point of failure or single person or
entity that can be gone after in various
ways
you might want to do it to create user
demand sometimes we see these cases
where people are actually very excited
about the chance to to be part of a
project that is collectively governed so
it's like a completely different
motivation from the first
and the third is this broader idea of
sort of like using it to build trust
right if this is a long run project you
want people to build on top of your
protocol you want people to come and
work with you partner with you in
different ways to be able to say this is
governed by the community might be
helpful in creating those Partnerships
and in building that long run trust so
those are three common motivations I see
all of which draw on historical
experiences and research that I'll talk
a little bit about obviously
there are downsides to building out
governance in a democratic way for any
of these right and so democracy as a
general thing is an incredibly powerful
tool it's also like a super blunt
instrument with a lot of downsides right
so we know we've probably all
experienced it in various ways it's slow
it's prone to conflict it's if
participation is low it's very prone to
interest group capture which we see in
Dow governance from time to time uh and
so forth you would never design a
smartphone through a democratic process
right and so the question is where do
you want to use this incredibly powerful
but incredibly complicated tool you
don't want to use it everywhere right we
know one uses it everywhere you want to
use it where it draw you know where the
value to using it far exceeds these
costs
so that's what we're going to think
about okay so I'm going to run through
these three goals and tell you a little
bit about why they you know make sense
and give you some examples of projects
that I think fit these goals in
different ways okay so the first one is
this very popular phrase resisting
censorship where it could mean a lot of
different things but the basic idea
is that write a big promise of web 3 is
that you can create these long-lived
protocols and no one can mess with them
in some sense right and so so some of
that is baked in a lot of that perhaps
is baked into blockchain and you don't
need to add governance to your project
to enjoy the benefits that are just
baked into blockchain right the
immutability and so forth however
it's basically impossible as far as I
know maybe someone can can tell me
otherwise as far as I can see there is
essentially no important protocol or
open source software project more
generally where there's never any new
decision that has to be made right the
world change at a minimum the world
changes and you have to decide something
about how to update the protocol or
change it in some way maybe you just but
then there's a much broader set of
things that also tends to happen it
tends to be that there need to be
strategic decisions made what's the
Future Vision of this project uh
sometimes Revenue comes in what are you
going to do with the treasury those are
all governance decisions that go beyond
something that can be just ossified and
made unchanging right and so that's
where governance comes in where
decisions have to be made
and what people have discovered over
time in web 3 is that that could be an
area
we're using the tools of democracy is
valuable if you want to remain in this
sort of like censorship resistant world
and you want to be able to say this is a
democratically governed project right
Anonymous entities anywhere in the world
can join this project and be part of its
governance no one is in charge and that
can be quite valuable for some projects
and that's a tool that that's something
that democracy might be able to help us
with however to do that obviously
democracy has to work
okay and one of the challenges here that
we've seen so far which is completely
unsurprising if you've you know spent
time in other types of democratic
systems is that it's hard to get people
to participate so this is some data from
a project
um that we're working on here at
Stanford uh with Dan Bonnet into two CS
students here where we're putting
together all of the voting data from
Dows that are on ethereum
um and so this is preliminary I want to
assess we're not done with the project
yet eventually it'll be a live dashboard
that you can check out if you want but
but what's already emerging from this
data is exactly what we already know
from experience in the space which is
that it's hard to get people to vote and
most people don't vote so what I'm
showing you here these bars are of all
the tokens outstanding in each of these
Dows how many on average are used to
vote on any given proposal in the Dow
and even those like wide bars at the top
which are complete outliers and actually
projects I'm not personally familiar
with
um even those wide bars out there are
under 30 which is significantly worse
than basically any major democracy in
the physical world even though we often
complain about low turnout in the
physical world and you'll see most of
them are like rounding errors I played
with different we could have used logs
or something but I I just want to kind
of make it clear that the levels here
are really small and major major uh
projects are away at the bottom here
right maker I mean that's a huge deal
tiny tiny voting voting rate and so if
very few people are voting that has a
lot of potential downsides and so like
for one thing you know in terms of
aggregating information to make the best
possible decision by voting it's
obviously bad if the vast majority of
people aren't voting and of course it
makes it harder to sustain the idea that
this is a collectively governed entity
and not something that's managed by a by
a small number of people and so so for a
wide variety of reasons this has become
an important area of study like how do
we get uh participation to go up okay so
I want to talk about a specific example
of this and some of the interesting
things that are going on with it so
maker you know one of the very largest
Dows by tvl one of the oldest Dows one
of the most creative with its governance
in many ways an inspiration for for the
space in general also the first special
place in my heart it was the first Dao
that I sort of spent time studying and
hanging out with
and it's a super super interesting
organization that's done a lot of really
thoughtful things on government so what
have they done over time in this vein of
resisting censorship well
they started out in a way a lot of
projects now start out there one of the
the first to explore this model right
like the first they had a foundation and
the foundation kind of directed things
and paid people and got things done
and then over time as it sort of took
off they dissolved the foundation right
and there now isn't a foundation and
things in some genuine sense are driven
by the community
and they had this super interesting
model which they're now changing in kind
of interesting ways around what they
called core units right and so people
could come along
hopefully this is the optimistic
description find a need that the project
had that wasn't being fulfilled propose
a new core unit of people to fulfill
that need to work on it and a budget how
much they would need to be paid to to do
that uh and get approved and actually go
do it and so in some sense the community
really did Drive the Bus and still is
today
however right there's been a bunch of
challenges to that and so maker has
really like almost every challenge we
see in Dow government today maker has
already seen before and that's why it's
such an interesting and important
project and so what are some of the
problems well
when you create a super decentralized
process where anyone can come and form a
team and propose uh to get funded
it's very natural whether or not the
money is being spent prudently it's just
natural for people to start worrying
that it's not because you're not around
all the time you don't feel it you start
to worry that sort of like a lot of
waste is going on and so one of the
things that the maker Community has
really battled over is sort of like is
all this spending Justified or are we
burning our money and should we have
fewer core units and that's been a big a
big debate that's been going on the
second thing which goes back to that
graph is that they're very aware right
that the that the participation rates
are low and they've explored some I
think really smart ways uh to try to
improve it so one thing they've been out
in front on is creating an official
program of Delegation right so they
recognize that basically direct
democracy is Not Practical for the
reasons I said before so let's have
delegates and let's pay them and the
maker delegates get paid quite a
significant amount of money to be sort
of like full-time governance
um experts if you will and so that might
help with the participation problem of
course you still need to get the average
user to pay enough attention to delegate
which is its own challenge but it seems
like a step in the right direction
another thing they've explored in which
I've done some research on I just want
to mention briefly is another thing you
could do taking advantage of like the
token structure is actually provide
direct rewards for voting and that's
something that more projects are now
exploring in the space and something I'm
really interested in studying so we
propose a particular mechanism to set
the price at which you reward people to
vote and some projects are trying to
implement that and I'm super curious to
see if it'll work it seems like
something at least worth trying given
that you know we would like to get the
participation rates up
okay the second purpose
uh is to stimulate user demand is to get
people excited right there's a wide
range of applications where to be able
to say to people if you come and join
this community or you buy this token or
whatever you get to be a participant a
contributor to the decisions we make as
a collective that can be very appealing
to people
of course the counter argument right I
mean there's two counter arguments one
would be what I said before that like
it's hard to participate and people
don't like it all the time sometimes
they just want to enjoy the service
and the second counter argument would be
there can be lip service paid to this
idea that you're part of the community
but if you're only one vote among many
like what contribution you're really
making and so there's like a challenge
here in terms of getting this right and
making people genuinely feel bought into
the community but if you can do it I
think it's a very it can be a very
powerful phenomenon and we've seen that
um in quite a few projects where you
kind of create this governance flywheel
by which I mean uh some people start
this thing maybe it's a group of friends
or people who've met each other online
in various ways right and they get
really into it and they create a system
that makes new people want to join those
people join and discover wow this is
actually it is fun to actually be part
of the decision making process and that
and then they come up with new stuff to
do maybe they fund some new projects
that make the community even more
appealing and then more people want to
come in and do the same thing and you
kind of rinse and repeat that right and
that's like a thing that a lot of people
are trying to achieve through governance
but it's it's actually it's very nuanced
it's hard to get that off the ground
sometimes it seems to happen by pure
luck how can you bottle that and repeat
it is like a big question I think in Dow
governance
um perhaps the like most famous example
of this is nouns right where it's like
in some sense this arbitrary thing where
each day you have the opportunity to you
know bid in an auction for a noun if you
win it you become a voting member of
this thing one noun is you know it comes
out each day
and it or very early on
it sort of created this really cool
Snowball Effect where people were like
this is a really cool Community I want
to be part of this and then it's the
flywheel really started to spin because
the the nouns became quite expensive
which meant that there's now this large
treasury that this community is in
charge of which makes new people want to
cut so then a lot of interesting stuff
gets funded right and that makes new
people want to come in and be part of
that because there's something real
going on here and so the nouns is you
know probably the single most Salient
example of this but there are of course
lots of others right and so and nouns
you know they've for example they've
like released basically the whole
governance tooling of nouns so you can
kind of fork it and do whatever you want
with it and there's lots of interesting
stuff being built um on top of nouns so
it's a it's a great example of this
the last one is like the broadest
motivation and I would say is the
closest to the history of corporate
governance okay and this is this idea
that by having something governed by the
people who've invested in it by having
something governed by the people who are
contributing to it
you're creating what we in social
science we call credible commitments
like you're able to promise that in the
future this project is going to make
decisions consistent with the interests
of the people who are empowered to be
part of its governance and that can be
very valuable think about like what's
going on with Apple today
right where some developers now are
reluctant to start putting in a lot of
effort to make something new for the App
Store obviously people are still doing
it it's necessary but like people on the
margin are reluctant because they don't
know what's going to happen in the
future are the rules going to change so
my apps don't allow it anymore are the
fees going to go up am I going to be
allowed to process payments the way I
want to and so forth on the margin those
are all kind of like bad features for
long-term innovation in a market
and if you can create instead a model
where you say decisions we make in the
future about how this thing works about
the rules about who's allowed to develop
on this thing about how fees are those
are going to be made through a process
that includes all of you you're going to
be part of the decision that's a way to
create what we call a credible
commitment that's a way for you to trust
now that five years from now your
interests are still going to be aligned
with this protocol and so that's
potentially very powerful
if you set it up right and things go
well right it's still obviously hard and
so you have to decide you know who are
the stakeholders who I need to be part
of this governance system so that they
feel like in the long run their
interests uh are being represented and
then you have to decide like how to
represent their interests and I'll give
you I just want to give you two examples
of this uh and then I'll wrap up with
some some more concrete discussions of
like how to actually do all these things
in practice so two really great examples
that are top of mind for me and and two
projects where I've been spending a lot
of my time studying lately one is Lido
which I believe is now larger than maker
uh so it's you know huge tvl uh kind of
a new from endow perspective right so
it's sort of like plugging into proof of
stake on ethereum and people are worried
and have been for some time now since
ethereum since the merge
the Lido has become too big right in the
sense that too large of a fraction of
all the staking and ethereum is going
through this intermediate protocol that
people are worried about that and then
it's creating it's not really all the
way to a single point of failure but
there's a concern that there's like a
concentrated risk with Lido and so
that's a problem for Lido obviously the
problem for the community if that's if
it's true if some people debate whether
it's true or not I don't I don't know
enough to make any claims there but the
fact that it could be true or that
people believe it could be true is
itself a problem not only for the
community of large but for lydo
specifically because lydo wants to exist
into the future and succeed and if
people don't trust it then that's bad
for it so how can they use governance to
try to solve this problem it comes back
to exactly what I just said it's about
bringing into the governance process the
people whose incentives you need to
align and so in particular what Lido is
working on now and you can go check this
out in their forums it's quite
interesting you can see a post first
post that I wrote there with Porter
um uh what are they trying to do they're
going to try instead of having just a
normal token-based Dow governance model
they're going to take that normal model
and they're going to add to it a new
veto
that occur that can be used can be
triggered by people who hold staked eth
which is the thing lydo issues to people
when they lock up their eath with Lido
and so that they're calling it dual
governance it's almost like you know in
American politics we might almost call
it like bicameralism or divided
government or separation of powers
and what's the idea the idea is that if
a bunch of staked eth people whose
interests are to make sure that the
proof of stake system continues
operating
can block decisions that the ldo holders
make then that might assure them in the
future that the ldo holders can't do
something overly malicious
to the ethereum proof of stake system at
large so it's a way to create trust by
bringing in the people who you need to
trust you directly into your governance
model
super super interesting there's a lot of
design consideration of how you actually
make the veto work so this is not nearly
a finished thing but it's a very very
interesting Direction I think
okay
the last example I want to talk about is
actually a combination of several of
these goals it's both about I think
building trust and also getting people
to come into your community and that's
optimism and so optimism is a layer too
and what they have thought about and
this is a problem that's been around for
a while it's something vitalik has been
super outspoken about what's on their
mind is this idea that if all decisions
that you put to a dow all the things
that can't be ossified
are done through token voting then
you're really heavily weighting the
interests of a pretty small set of large
token holders right and that can be bad
if what you need for your project to
succeed in the long run is for there to
be a kind of a Vibrant Community of
other kinds of participants like people
who contribute to the project who hang
out in the Dow and do stuff for the Dow
who write extra code or build new tools
if if those people all have to be whales
before they feel like they have a role
to play in the project that can be very
bad
both for attracting people and for long
run convincing people that if this is
going to be a kind of a you know a broad
project that's supposed to appeal to a
lot of different types of people that
you can succeed in that if all you have
is token voting so what is optimism
doing they're experimenting with one I
think there's a whole range of things
you can do here they're experimenting
with one very interesting uh way to do
this which is that they're creating
another kind of bicameralism so Lido is
building in this veto to try to get
steak teeth holders to trust them
optimism is building a whole
decision-making apparatus for major
contributors to the community and the
way you become a member of this body is
not by holding lots of tokens it's by
creating a track record of having
contributed and participated in the
community and there's a super
interesting and thoughtful process
they've built out for how they decide
who meets those criteria and then once
you're in this body
you're part of a group that gets to
decide on how certain kinds of Treasury
funds are used in a kind of to support
public goods for the for the project at
large so it's a really interesting way
of trying to move Beyond pure token
voting and bring in these other
stakeholders who are important and try
to get them to be part of the process
you know I would say the challenges to
it are going to be kind of what I
alluded to before can you get these
people to consistently participate can
you create a fair process for choosing
who they are and can you give them
enough Powers so that it it's not lip
service so that they are really
meaningfully making Collective decisions
that people care about I think those are
always like fundamental questions about
these things
okay let me wrap up uh with some
thoughts on like those are the
overarching goals and considerations
and now they're sort of like well how do
you actually put this into practice and
oftentimes when I talk to projects
they're in this phase of sketching out
sometimes they call it a constitution
you know other times it's like a medium
post or doesn't quite feel as lofty as a
constitution but it's probably a
reasonable way to do it uh they're in
the process of writing out their
governance structure so that they can
explain it to the community and get
people's buy-in so how should you
actually do that what should you think
about
um I think there's probably a lot of
things that should go into that and I
won't claim to know anywhere close to
everything you should know to do that
well but here are I think four like key
questions for your Constitution
the first is scope what are the
decisions that the governance process is
going to make and so if we think back to
what I was talking about in terms of
goals right you may want there to be
almost no governance because you're
going to lock as much as you can into
just the way the the protocol is built
right or you might have a wide range of
decisions that you think need to be made
through governance because you're really
interested in some of those goals I
spoke to earlier that really require
buy-in and require a bunch of people to
believe the stakes are high and so forth
so there's you see a wide range of
projects so I would put maker for
example pretty far in terms of scope a
lot of stuff is decided through
governance I'll put you to swap farther
to the other side fewer things are
decided by governance though as we know
this week more than nothing is certainly
decided by governance
so that's a big one when you think about
how you're going to design your
governance system and you've identified
your goals in your mind like I know what
I want governance to achieve then that
should help you then specify here are
the things that are going to be decided
by governance the second thing which
also relates back to those goals is who
who gets to decide how are you
Distributing out your voting power how
are you you know giving out the tokens
but also if you're going Beyond token
voting how are you doing the other
things like that that's obviously
crucial
one thing I haven't talked about at all
yet which is where I actually spend a
lot of my time is this third category
the rules okay so you've decided these
big questions about what governance is
going to do and who's going to do it but
how are they actually going to do it and
there's a bunch of considerations here
about how do you implement voting and so
forth that I can talk about a little bit
and then finally there's the timeline
when are you going to to push out this
governance power and there's some you
know pros and cons of different ways of
doing that okay
I'm going to talk for about five more
minutes is that about right okay
um okay so let me take each of these
briefly in turn and then I'm going to
conclude
how much do you want governance to do as
I said there's a bunch of trade-offs and
considerations there's obviously no one
right answer if there's if you take one
thing away from at least my view on all
this stuff is that there is no one
governance model that works for everyone
it's completely context dependent so
less governance try to push as much
stuff as you can just into the way the
thing is designed built and used leave
as little as possible for Collective
decisions through voting and other types
of governance you know what does that do
obviously the fewer things you have to
decide through voting the faster you can
go voting is just slow you got day yeah
I mean if you've ever spent any time on
Dows you know
you gotta like Walk The Halls that's
what we call in Academia that's where
you go around and tell everyone about
your proposal and then you hear that
it's terrible and you change it that can
take months
um to say nothing of how long it takes
in Academia uh
it's obviously faster if you're doing as
little as possible by voting right so if
you want to make a ton of decisions
quickly like you don't want to be using
voting a lot okay
likewise if you're the founder of a
project it is very likely that you know
more than anyone else in the world about
what the right decisions are for that
project to make so why would you want to
give over those decisions to people who
might not know as much right so that's
another argument for you're going to
lower the risk of bad decisions or
increase the probability of good
decisions for at least some domain of
decisions where your experience and
expertise is especially relevant okay
and you're also going to have less
conflict maybe that's actually a little
bit debatable but like you're not going
to have the kind of
Collective conflict that is kind of the
bread and butter of democracy but but
the other side of that coin right is by
keeping it not very democratically
governed you're getting less of that
buy-in from people who are excited to
participate you're getting less of that
sense of trust you have maybe a less
good story for users you have a less
good story for your censorship
resistance potentially depending uh and
maybe most problematically for all those
things there may actually be a bunch of
collective decisions that are still
being made but they're being made in a
kind of hidden way where you don't
realize it okay and so those are some of
the downsides now you can go over here
and you can have tons of governance
leave lots of decisions up to this
governance process that could be good
for those that buy-in and Trust I was
talking about it might bring users in it
makes the process very explicit and
transparent this is how we make these
decisions you're going to see the whole
thing
but it's slow it can lead to bad
decisions whether because people just
don't know what they're doing they're
like speculating more than you would be
if you made the decision or because
someone with a defined you know interest
comes in and captures the process so
imagine a worst case you know worst case
a bad case scenario where someone comes
to your dad and says I have this great
Consulting project you just pay me five
million dollars and I'll do a great job
you know doing whatever for your gal and
I'm gonna buy I'm going to buy a million
dollars of tokens to vote in favor of
awarding me five million dollars for
this contract or stuff like that happens
That's a classic case of a concentrated
interest group capturing a process and
that's more likely to happen in a world
where not very many people are
participating so there's so there's like
pros and cons here to anywhere on the
Spectrum it's a trade-off there's no
right answer it depends what you're
trying to do okay who gets to decide
classic bread and butter political
science question you you can you know it
used to be early on my impression right
that it was common to hold a lot of the
tokens for yourself now over time that's
becoming less common why for a lot of
reasons but a major one is that as
people pay more attention that seems
less fair and it it leaves the rest of
the people you need to buy into your
project feeling like why should I buy
into this I'm not really part of this
right so over time I would say at least
for the kind of like
very high profile most exciting projects
there's been a lot of work to like
figure out fairer ways to distribute
voting power that could take the form of
you know tokens but as I said before it
could also take the form of going Beyond
token voting and using some of these
other tricks like identifying people
who've contributed a lot and giving them
like a non-transferable token that
allows them to vote things like that
again there's like a trade-off here
right there's something very elegant and
simple to the pure token voting model
it's like shareholder voting in in the
corporate world it concentrates voting
power with people who have the most at
stake who might have the most
information about the decision being
made but on the other hand it feels less
fair and less representative of a
broader group of people who you might
want to be included in your process so
there's again like potentially big
trade-offs there okay the rules I could
have given a whole talk just about the
rules but I actually think
the voting rules are one of the less
important parts of dalgar when I got
into this space I thought it would be
all voting rules because that's like
what I like to do but uh but it turns
out there's a lot of excitement about
implementing different types of voting
rules and it is something that
technology enables but what I've
observed is that all these other things
I've just talked about those are the big
the big matzah balls like in terms of
stuff you have to decide how you vote is
less important I think most of the time
than structuring it so that you're
making the right decisions and have the
right people voting once you have those
two things the outcomes often aren't
that strongly a function of the way you
vote for a reasonable plausible ways you
might vote nevertheless there are some
that I think are super valuable so one
thing I talked about earlier which uh
which I also have a piece about that you
can check out if you're interested is
this idea that delegation or liquid
democracy as people are sometimes
calling it in the space
um
I like how everything gets rebranded
um uh we would call it representative
democracy maybe
um uh that could be a really good idea
and it can be a really good idea for the
reasons I described it we know direct
democracy doesn't really work
shareholder voting also doesn't work
very well and actually it has liquid
democracy in it they call it proxy
voting it's a way more boring name
um so that seems like a very smart Rule
and I would say over time more and more
of the projects I talk to are using some
kind of Delegation by default I think
there's a lot more work that can be done
to make delegation better and to get
more people delegating but it seems like
kind of a table Stakes idea at this
point I also mentioned in terms of rules
you might want to explore thinking about
directly rewarding for participation
through voting so like imagine you have
a new project you have some kind of
native token you might give people
rewards denominated in that native token
as part of this like broader effort to
incentivize participation and coming
back to like the optimism style idea of
including those people in governance in
different ways
there's a lot of energy around like more
complicated ways to total up people's
votes so like quadratic voting is
something you might hear about
conviction voting things like that
I think they all have a place they're
all if you like go read the academic
papers on them you got to find like what
is the objective function being
maximized by this idea and then you got
to map that to the goal you have in mind
and make sure they're equal because
otherwise it's like it's not they're not
multi-purpose tools right they're all
optimized for some you know welfare
function
um I'm a bit of a skeptic that any of
those are like first order priorities
for projects when I hang out with them
it's much harder to figure out like how
are we gonna get people to vote at all
like what are they going to decide on
how do we make these decisions well more
than like is the problem that we need to
reflect intensity of preference in the
voting tool that we use so that's kind
of my view on this but I mean I think it
is interesting that there are all these
options now
finally
this is my last slide basically uh on
the timeline here
there's like a trade this is a graphic I
borrowed with with citation from an
interesting blog blog post on this
um you often see the following sequence
which is depicted here which is like
first you spend all of your time
figuring out what your project does like
why should people want to use it what is
its utility
after you find that people start to use
it and pay attention to it are
interested in it then you start to kind
of like bootstrap a community around it
it may ideally for some projects at
least that's organic people are psyched
about this tool and so they show up and
they want to create a community because
then this this parallels
physical world history too like it's a
lot easier to build community and
democracy organically than to try to
like top down Planet it's not impossible
to build top-down States like it's been
done but it's a lot harder and so if you
can have this organic creation of a
community that's very helpful and then
in the kind of the third phase here is
you can start that process of
progressive decentralization where this
naturally growing Community takes on
more and more formal Powers over time so
that's a that's a sequence you'll often
see with a lot of projects where when
they're new they're like they're talking
about governance they're exploring it
but they're not really using it yet
and I just want to flag that can be very
very smart I mean it's just logical but
also can be very very smart because if
you go too big too fast you face this
very unpleasant asymmetry which is that
if you give out power you can't really
take it back especially in the
blockchain context right like and so
this is for example is a theme just to
go back to my Lido example imagine
you're going to get give out a veto to
the stake teeth holders and you one of
the things you have to decide when you
give out a veto is like what's the
threshold for the veto to be triggered
and imagine you set the veto as any one
steak to eat voting is a veto and you
implement that you've basically now
risked permanently thrashing the whole
project right because now any one steak
to eat can veto anything you want to do
and you can't undo it because the
decision to undo that rule would itself
be vetoable
and so you want to be really careful
when you roll out new governance powers
and this is exactly what happens in the
real world like back when parliaments
were taking on new powers this is
exactly the concern like you know from
the perspective of these sort of like
Elites or whatever you want to call them
was like how much power do we want to
give out and will it be you know if it
goes really badly can we pull it back
like No And so this like Progressive
rolling out of governance makes a lot of
sense however there is a downside right
which is if you think the governance is
critical to those things I talked about
before like if your project is of the
form where for example like telling
people right up front that they're going
to be part of the decision making
process is part of the service is part
of what you're offering then obviously
you can't wait like you need the
governance on day one so so it really
depends again on your use case okay
that's what I have for you today uh uh
happy to stop here and take questions
I'll just flag this is my concluding
slide for you there's a ton I haven't
obviously haven't talked about and so
like if you actually are I tried to give
you kind of like the conceptual things
that I think are worth thinking about
the questions you might ask yourself the
trade-offs involved there's a lot of
like nuts and bolts thing that I didn't
touch on many of which I you know I'm
not even expert on obviously so you
build out governance obviously you want
to like get people to audit your code
um you want to draw from existing
governance smart contracts where you can
presumably there's a bunch of best
practices you want to get familiar with
so that you don't like have these super
embarrassing governance attacks that
still happen in new projects sometimes
when they don't follow best practices
just like an example of that would be
like you don't want to create a system
where it's possible to like take out a
flash loan for 51 of your voting power
vote with it and then give the flash
loan back so stuff like that there's
also like a pretty
broad set of services that can help you
like get your message board going like
get people participating and stuff so
that's the kind of thing you want to
think about
and the last is just like what I observe
of successful projects is like they're
walking the Halls as I said like they're
going to all the people who are involved
and coordinating with them making sure
that like if a proposal is coming up
that everyone knows about it and so
forth and that's the kind of like soft
governance stuff you want to think about
as well so I will stop there happy to
field some questions
thank you so much for the talk uh I have
one quick question going all the way
back to your talk which you mentioned uh
you know we have this new technology you
know this we're repeating a lot of the
experimentation any mistakes we had
before but you know it must be going
somewhere new where do you think that
somewhere new is and why do you why do
you think that it's a good question I
think there's a couple for me
there's a couple new parts to it that
I'm particularly excited about one is
this idea that like large online
platforms
now play a role in our society that's
almost like quasi-governmental and some
of the decisions that they're making and
because they like span the globe and
because they like have these various
particular use cases that policy makers
aren't that familiar with
we need some other way to like govern
them and so I think these tools provide
a plausible path I think to a future
where like very large online platforms
are not governed entirely by like one
executive or one board of directors but
rather by some combination of I think
realistically there probably should
always be Executives in like a
corporation but they could also have
users you know developers sellers
creators whatever as part of the
governance process and you really need
something like blockchain technology I
think to make that credible to create
those credible commitments that's like
I'm going to give you voting power on
like you know this social media platform
and I'm not going to be able to take it
away from you so that's one very broad
domain I'm super excited about in terms
of more specifically like on the kind of
like the governance tools themselves one
of the things I think is that I didn't
realize it took me like a year of
working in this space before I realized
this really came from the Lido stuff
this idea that you can create a
governance system with these additional
rules or constraints on what decisions
can be made beyond the 51 voting for it
so the idea that you could hard code in
a veto let's say
um I think that potentially opens up a
lot a pretty wide space of like
legislative design that we don't have
access to in the real world so in the
real thing about the US the U.S has this
filibuster thing which is something
other than a 51 voting rule
and it is stuck for a while now because
both parties make this calculation that
like if I get rid of this which I'm
perfectly free to do like you can just
instantly get rid of it if you're in the
majority you can just vote and say like
we don't want that anymore why don't
they do that well they kind of are now
over time they're like chipping away at
it why don't they just go all the way
and get rid of it it's because they're
worried that that's going to create some
kind of repeat Tit for Tat where then
when the other party's in charge
something even worse is going to happen
so and so it sustains for a little while
but it those kind of rules don't sustain
in the long run because at any point
there's this idea called remote
majoritarianism which is that like 51 of
legislators could always vote to change
anything because it's the only reversion
point it's like the one thing we can all
agree on is that a majority rules
everything else that's built on top of
that is inherently fragile like a
majority could always decide to undo it
by just voting to undo it and blockchain
and Dallas is the first thing I have
ever seen where like you could hard code
in some other Rule and the majority
can't undo it at least in the same way
like you'd have to you know fork and
stuff and that might not work and so
that I think is it creates a whole set
of commitments that aren't possible in
legislatures that could be quite
valuable though I don't know where yet
um and then the last thing I'll say is
kind of like just softer but like just
this ability this ability for like
anonymous groups across the world to
freely enter and exit and like quickly
make decisions or not make decisions
um I think that that will be a very
natural extension of like what we see in
corporate governance today and you can
imagine like some kind of interesting
Global entities of the future that like
are governed that way which wouldn't be
possible in corporations today
yeah one more question
try to squeeze you into
cool
um yeah thanks a lot
um so I had a question um you said in
the beginning that that those are very
novel because they draw on blockchain
technology and and I think one of the
other things that is very novel about
them is that they don't really are
situated in any particular country or
governance or anything like this so I
was wondering if you could expand a bit
on like what are the properties of
Dallas come from that that like yeah
that that
like that that fact that they basically
are not backed by institutions and they
can't draw on like legal systems for
kind of like governance
yeah I don't know I don't know I think
I've definitely thought about that a lot
I would say probably relative maybe to
most people here relative to the
community I'm like more pragmatist than
most people and so I I think eventually
they will be integrated into the legal
system we do have lots of historical
examples of like
weird new things that cut across Global
jurisdictions the internet was this way
and they just kind of like figured it
out it took a long time the history of
that stuff I think would be super
interesting like if you haven't
experience it like take a look I have
this theory that like the history of
eBay kind of explains like everything
that happens online because eBay has
lived through like all of this stuff and
so like oh you think like Facebook was
the first company ever to face these
like content moderation controversies
like nope in the early 90s people were
selling Nazi memorabilia on eBay and in
France it's illegal to do that and they
got sued and it came to this exact
question of like well this is a global
company where what country do we even
Sue it in and and they just kind of like
figured it out over time and kind of
muddled through and so I can my my view
is in the future there they will
somehow figure it out and there'll be
layers to this so there will be a layer
of like you know hopefully somewhat
sensible
laws and policies that sort of hash
those things out and then on top of that
can be these very interesting Global
entities I have I'm not a lawyer I have
no idea how they'll deal with it but
like long term I kind of one of my views
on global
governments is that they're like really
good at figuring stuff out when it like
affects their bottom line and I just
think long run they're like you know
this is why I'm a complete this is a
long answer your question about why I'm
a complete pessimist on this like
Network State type stuff is like
governments have the weapons like they
they're in charge
um and I think they will be for a really
long time probably for the best also in
my personal view but yeah the long
answer to your question
thank you
I'll hang I'll hang for a couple minutes
after yeah yeah yeah thank you everyone